trafic aérien réponse d'air france à la
guerre des tarifs sur l'atlantique nord
des vols vacances à bord d'avions de
grandes capacités vont être inaugurés à
partir de mes proches il ne s'agit pas
de charter puisque ces voyages seront
régulièrement programmées mais les prix
seront tout de même très compétitif les
caractéristiques de ces nouveaux
services vont être des avions à nombre
de sièges plus élevé tout en gardant un
confort aussi voisins que possible du
transport du confort de la place
économique actuel mais avec un service
au sol et un service à bord très
simplifiées en particulier les repas
seront des repas froids et par
conséquent beaucoup plus économique
les tarifs les tarifs vont être des
tarifs qui vont être tout à fait
compétitif avec les tarifs les plus bas
pratiqué actuellement sur les
destinations internationales par exemple
de l'ordre de
17 cents et quelques francs en 1960
franc suivant les saisons sur new york
2000 à 2300 francs sur les antilles ce
qui donne exactement le même tarif au
siège kilomètre et ainsi tué 2 400
francs pour paris londres 6 à 700 francs
pour alma de 13700 en france sur sur tel
aviv